[Music]
welcome back so I've been telling you a
lot about sparsity and compress sensing
and this idea that as long as your
signal that you're trying to estimate
has patterns like an image or an audio
signal you can get away with
surprisingly few measurements if there's
some element of randomness to how you're
measuring that system okay now today I'm
going to tell you about a little bit of
a different perspective on sparse
sensing for classification tasks so if
my goal is not to reconstruct a full
image but rather to classify what's in
the image you can get away with a lot
fewer measurements so that's what I want
to talk about we've seen this picture
before that the reason kind of
compressed sensing works in general is
because pixel space kind of the space of
possible signals is absolutely
astronomical it's bigger than
astronomical of all possible images that
you could ever see and natural images
the images that we as humans care about
live in a tiny tiny tiny fraction of
image space and it's diffuse and spread
out around image space but natural
images occupy a miniscule almost
unimaginably small fraction of pixel
space even though image space itself is
unimaginably large all of your human
existence and everything you could ever
see lives here but it's still tiny
compared to the vastness of image space
and that was how we thought about why
kind of compressed sensing was possible
at the first place and so I should point
out that this lecture is gonna follow
ideas from this paper 2016 paper in the
siam journal of applied math by my wife
bing Brunton myself josh proctor and
nathan cuts so you can kind of read
therefore a lot more mathematical
details on what we're gonna talk about
but the basic idea is that if we're not
trying to reconstruct a full image if
we're not trying to get a
high-resolution reconstruction of what's
in our image let's say we only want to
classify what's in our image so instead
of trying to determine what exact
what exact picture of a dog we have or
what picture of a cat I just want to do
a binary classification is there a dog
or is there a cat in my image is it a
dog or is it a cat and so this idea that
if all we want to do is classify what's
in our image you can get away with many
many many fewer measurements than if you
had to reconstruct the image and this is
what we call enhanced sparsity for
decision making ok and in fact the
algorithm that we introduced is called
Spock sparse sensor placement
optimization for classification Spock ok
and it's based on this idea then if all
you want is a classification of your
image you can get away with many fewer
sensors or pixels than if you wanted to
reconstruct so the idea is I don't care
if my you know if the picture of the dog
is a bulldog or a shih tzu that's kind
of perpendicular to this line I don't
care about any information that's
perpendicular to this decision line I
don't care what type of cat I have over
here all I care about are the features
that maximally tell me the difference
between dogs and cats ok and so that
that's the basic idea here and I'm gonna
walk you through the algorithm it's
actually a very simple algorithm and we
have some variants and there's been some
follow-up papers since but in its
simplest formulation it's quite
intuitive how this works okay so this is
Bing this is her paper you know I helped
out but but I'm kind of walking you
through through her 2016 paper so this
idea of targeted sensor placement for
classification I'm going to walk through
on two examples kind of the dogs and
cats examples and then the eigenfaces
example so the idea is you have a really
big training data set so again we're
always thinking about this and kind of
the machine learning way that you have a
big training data set and you're gonna
do some offline training to learn
features about your data and then you're
gonna use that to make a really fast or
really good online decision with less
information potentially so here I have
my my dogs and cats library so a bunch
of cats a bunch of dogs here I have my
my faces library this is only a small
subset of many thousands of images of
people's faces and the first step
that you do is you run something like a
singular value decomposition or a
principal component analysis to find
some low dimensional feature space that
describes your data okay so over here
you have your eigen faces here you have
your eigen pets okay so you can really
nicely describe this data by only a few
orthogonal vectors or orthogonal images
in these eigen pets and eigenfaces space
so maybe your faces had you know hundred
thousand pixels here you can get away
with a hundred IDing faces here your
dogs and your cats maybe had thirty
thousand pixels in these images I can
get away with ten or twenty Augen pets
okay and that's given by this this
matrix side this is literally from the
singular value decomposition that map's
my high dimensional image into a low
dimensional space and then what you're
counting on is that in this low
dimensional space of eigen pets or or
eigenfaces your categories separate so
you're counting on dogs and cats kind of
separating being separate clusters in
this in this feature space in this
pattern extracted eigen space and so if
that's true if your dogs and your cats
live in different regions and kind of
separate or cluster in this in this in
this case in my eigen pets space then
you can use our Spock algorithm okay so
this is it's a lot of ifs but a lot of
systems this is true this is how image
classification used to work before deep
neural networks is you would take your
data you'd map into some feature space
like eigenfaces and you would basically
cluster your data and define these
decision lines where you can separate
your data and make decisions that's how
support vector machines works that's how
Fisher discriminant works linear
discriminant analysis lots and lots of
classical image classification
techniques are based on this this idea
okay so I hope you're following you have
dogs and cats you pull out their
features and in that feature space they
cluster into these kind of groups of
dogs and cats and you could design a
line a decision boundary that would tell
you if you're on one side you're a cat
if you're on your other side you're a
doc okay and we define that decision
boundary we define the line that
maximally separates these two clusters
by this vector W in feature space okay
and we get this using the linear
discriminant analysis but you could use
other techniques and then the last step
here is that once you have these
clusters in feature space that are
separated by this vector W you can run
this optimization algorithm at the top
and this is almost exactly like the
compressed sensing algorithm it's an l1
minimized regression problem where
you're trying to make you're trying to
fit your your data your observations and
what we're doing is we're getting a
sparse vector s that is the same size as
the original image but the individual
pixel locations in s tell you where is
best to measure for this classification
task and here in the case of my eigen
pets and eigenfaces these are where the
red sensors fall out of the data and
it's really interesting these are
extremely intuitive placements so the
sensors for the cat are in the eyes the
ears the snout that's where kind of the
cat and the dog are the most different
or the eyes the nose and the ears for
humans you also get a lot of sensors in
the corners of the eyes corner of the
nose regions where there's a lot of
variability and we're different people
look very different okay and we didn't
tell the algorithm anything we didn't
say that these are humans or dogs or
cats we just gave examples of the data
we gave examples of dogs and cats
we ran singular value decomposition or
principal components to get the features
and then we we plotted this data in this
low dimensional space to find out that
it did in fact cluster and since it
clustered we could find this
discriminant line and determine these
optimal sensor locations for that
classification task so I want to talk a
little bit about dimensions because I
think this will help you understand a
little bit more let's say that this is
I'm just gonna make numbers up that kind
of at random here let's say that all of
my pictures over here are megapixel
images they have a million pixels okay
and let's say that over here
I can get away with 20 I can cats and
dogs for a good classification okay so
this is a million pixels this is a 20
dimensional feature space so when I map
into that 20 dimensional feature space
I'm doing this classification on those
20 numbers of kind of what is my mixture
of those 20 eigen pets that make up each
of those high-res images so this is a 20
dimensional space and W is a vector in
20 dimensions so what I'm trying to do
now is I'm trying to find a full
resolution image that when I map it into
this feature space it is gives me the
most information in this W direction
because that's where all of my
classification information is happening
is in this W direction I don't care
about anything perpendicular I don't
care about what kind of dog or what kind
of cat I just care about the information
that separates them and so by running
this optimization to find the sparse
cysts
s possible that reconstructs my decision
vector when mapped into feature space
that's how we're pulling out this vector
s that has these nonzero these twenty
nonzero entries and because we have a
twenty dimensional feature space we
generally get twenty nonzero entries and
s corresponding to the absolute best
locations to measure for this
classification task now this is a really
cool idea and we've applied this to lots
of systems since and it seems to work
quite well something interesting that
Bing did is she you can do this with a
kind of random reshuffling so I'll just
walk you through this again so this was
a large library of eigenfaces so what
you can do is you can take 80% of your
data at random train this algorithm get
20 sensors then do another random 80%
train and get another 20 sensors you do
that over and over and over again and
you can plot an ensemble of where those
sensors are most likely to appear and
this is what that ensemble looks like
for the eigenfaces so it starts to patch
out kind of this ghosty outline of human
features of what you would look at and
there's classical results from the 60s
this Y Arbus result where they did I try
and they should people pictures of human
faces and tract where their eyes look at
to determine who that that person is and
you can see that where the human eye
spends the most time is very similar to
where our algorithm spends the most time
okay so I think that's really kind of a
neat a neat connection between kind of
classical results in human vision and
cognition and this kind of modern
machine learning perspective if you
trained an algorithm to pick the best
sensors they would actually get a lot of
the same features that a human does ok
so this is a really powerful algorithm
you can use this for classification
tasks and instead of needing you know
ten thousand or a hundred thousand
random pixel measurements for compressed
sensing we can get away with twenty
pixels and classify really really
accurately you know dogs versus cats or
different types of different individual
humans I will point out that this does
in fact require that the images are
cropped and aligned if you're going to
use singular value decomposition or
principal components as the features but
if you're willing to do something a
little fancier for your feature space
you might be able to get around some of
those limitations so in principle you
could embed this into neural network
architectures and other classification
algorithms that are a bit more powerful
okay so the last thing I want to point
out and I think this is just really fun
is that we didn't start thinking about
sparse sensor placement and
classification at random okay this is
not just you know a random research
topic we got interested in this because
of this kind of bio-inspired sensing
that we observe in insects so and I'll
most certainly do kind of a whole
lecture on this at some other point
about bio-inspired sensing but I'll just
give you a little high-level right now
there's this idea that not an idea it's
an observation that all flying insects
have on the order of tens to hundreds of
strain sensitive neurons on their wings
so if you look with a microscope at a
moth wing or a fruit fly wing there will
be lots and lots and lots of these tiny
tiny tiny strain sensitive neurons
so they're literally neurons that are in
the wing so when the wing bends at a
certain temporal pattern or a certain if
it bends a certain way in time these
neurons fire ions get squeezed into a
nerve ending and those neurons fire and
all of that information goes up into the
central nervous system of this flying
insect and it uses that information to
help it fly better okay and we're still
trying to unravel kind of the neural
flight control system of flying insect
that's it's almost as if we have an
alien an alien spaceship landed on earth
and we're gonna try to reverse-engineer
how it flies that's what these flying
insects are to us and so there's this
observation that these insects can do
extremely sophisticated maneuvers and
flight control in time scales that are
faster then it's information goes to its
brain so it's visual information or
these sensors have time to go to its
brain and back to the muscles and so
what we believe is happening is that
these sensors are going directly into a
local computation in its kind of
shoulder muscle and then it's doing some
local computation and deciding
immediately what to send back to it's
it's it's muscles okay so it's kind of
bypassing the brain and doing this
really fast local computation based on
these strain sensitive neurons and so I
think this is a fascinating problem
we've been trying to understand for
years kind of reverse engineer
why would it put its sensors here these
are not in random locations they're in
very stereotyped very reproducible
locations what is it trying to estimate
why is it placing its sensors there are
the optimal locations all kinds of
questions you can ask to
reverse-engineer the system and then
also can we take wing technology from a
moth and can we use it in our everyday
engineering life can we learn how to
sense systems better more efficiently
and do local computations based on this
kind of sparse sensing paradigm of
flying insects so those are all super
interesting questions that's kind of
where this idea of sparse sensor
optimization for classification came
from
as we were trying to think you know okay
you have a moth flying maybe it just
wants to know am i rotating or not
that's a classic hypothesis of what it
could be using those strength sensitive
neurons for and we kind of took that
idea and mapped it into this general
mathematical framework where you can
start thinking about generic
classification tasks and how you would
target optimized sensors for those
classification tasks so there's a lot
more under the hood a lot I'm not
telling you about if you want to know
more please do read our papers check out
Chapter three of our new book
data-driven science and engineering by
myself and Nathan Cutts
there will be a link in the comments to
code to PDF and if you find this useful
please like please subscribe hit the
bell and let me know what you want me to
talk about and tell you more about
alright thank you